your body is made up of over 200 bones a
few trillion microbes and as many as 37
trillion cells and while death is often
thought of as the end of the line for
yourself your body still has a long way
to go it doesn't take long before your
body starts to lose what makes you you
just a few minutes after death one of
the first things to go is your brain you
see when your heart stops beating it
halts blood flow which is supposed to
transport oxygen to your organs and
tissues so without blood the most active
oxygen guzzling organs and tissues go
first
and the results are moist because the
cells that make up those organs and
tissues are 70% water without oxygen to
keep them alive the cells self-destruct
spilling all that fluid onto the coffin
floor by that night an even more
troubling process begins in the gut
you're dying immune system can no longer
contain the trillions of hungry microbes
that normally help digest the food you
eat
so they escape first they travel from
the lower intestines through your
tissues veins and arteries within hours
they reach your liver and gallbladder
which contain a yellow green bile meant
for breaking down fat when you're alive
but after the microbes are through
eating those organs that bile starts to
flood the body staining it a yellow
green from about day two to four the
microbes are everywhere and they're
producing toxic gases like ammonia and
hydrogen sulfide which will expand and
cause your body to not only bloat but
stink after three or four months your
yellow-green complexion has turned
brownish black because your blood
vessels have deteriorated to the point
that the iron inside them spills out
becoming brownish black as it oxidizes
also around this time the molecular
structures that hold your cells together
break away so your tissues collapse into
a watery mush
and in a little over a year your cotton
clothes disintegrate as acidic body
fluids and toxins break them down only
the nylon seams and waistband survived
at this point nothing dramatic happens
for a while but by a decade in given
enough moisture the wet low oxygen
environment sets off a chemical reaction
that turns the fat in your thighs and
butt to a soap-like substance called
grave wax on the other hand drier
conditions lead to mummification that's
right
you can mummify naturally no wrappings
chemicals or intimidating instruments
required because throughout this entire
decomposition process water is
evaporating through the thin skin on
your ears nose and eyelids causing them
to dry out and turn black
aka mummify by 50 years in your tissues
will have liquefied and disappeared
leaving behind de mummified skin and
tendons eventually those two will
disintegrate and after 80 years in that
coffin your bones will crack as the soft
collagen inside them deteriorates
leaving nothing but the brittle mineral
frame behind but even that shell won't
last forever a century in the last of
your bones will have collapsed into dust
and only the most durable part of your
body your teeth will remain teeth crave
wax and some nylon threads